i haven't said hello to this man and uh
since it was june it was a late june day
uh i'm i'm sitting in front of a green
screen for several hours with this man
uh and it was just a delight just a
delight to to hang with him and just see
how people react to him
just such a good dude and um an
outstanding host and anything that he
does
and uh it's because of i saw firsthand
that he and i together can make
beautiful music to make the jonas
brothers look like real olympic athletes
and joining me here on the rich eisen
show mercedes-benz vans phone line in
advance of rumble which is available for
streaming tomorrow on paramount plus the
great terry crews how you doing terry
hey rich how you doing man it's good to
hang with you again it is that was a fun
day that was it was a fun day that was
good we we did a miracle making them
look like olympic athletes that was
phenomenal it was and then we were
watching it we we we knew it was coming
obviously because we were we were
putting the show together and then uh we
couldn't believe it ended with with uh i
think nick jonas like breaking a rib and
we're like wait a minute like what i
know
you know the sports ain't no joke it's
what everybody has to get the message
that every
everyone has to get from that i know and
then i love seeing all these commercials
on uh sunday night football are you
promoting the upcoming olympic coverage
of winter olympic coverage
yeah i'm so proud of that man this
because these athletes are absolutely
incredible and it's kind of like
you know i can only imagine during a
pandemic yeah and the whole thing that
everyone's trying to get through
everything
and on top of that you have to keep your
keep up your shape and your skill level
it's just incredible man so i i was like
anything i could do to give them more
light and more help uh i'm in uh i'm a
fan well when you're not doing your 90
jobs terry crews um and you do have a
minute to watch a football game how do
you watch it do you do you still watch
it with like a football mind from your
years of playing it first of all i i
don't have that kind of time when i i'm
a sports center guy i literally what i
realized is that you can watch all the
games
by watching sportscenter all of it and
you don't miss a thing you literally did
not miss one thing at all if it was
worth watching it was shown you know i
mean so you don't just settle you just
don't settle in i'm like okay i'm gonna
take three hours and watch this football
game just talking about three hours oh
no oh no too much to do i i literally
have too much to do i i can't
three hours i can even take a nap
one of those hours and then it's time to
get back to work man it's you know it's
kind of like for right now i have to
strike while the iron's hot you know
what i'm saying well you're killing it
realize man these are opportunities that
may not come back again especially now
after after the whole world shut down
i'm taking advantage of everything so uh
do you ever dream that you're playing
football again do you ever have any one
of those terry yeah i've definitely had
football dreams man i you know i stay in
shape i yeah i literally i'm right now
i'm in probably the best shape of my
life i'm 235 but i'm not in hitting
shape like people forget the nfl you
know it's fine as an athlete but once
you take any of those hits it's like
being in a car accident every quarter
and it takes its toll and i had to
really i had to spend years healing up
after that no kidding the dream about
football but not doing it so are you
scoring in your dreams are you scoring
or you're taking something no i'm
hitting i i never was on the off i would
never consider myself on the offensive
side
so you never had in your three years you
never had a scoop and score for the rams
and the charges never
never i i was always hitting folks that
was my big highlight was i got knocked
out on monday night football i
you can you can google it google terry
crews knocked out on monday night
football it's right there is that real
chargers and we were playing
indianapolis colt who put you to sleep
who did that do you remember well i i
hit clarence burden who was the smallest
man in the nfl at the time
i hit him
and read the lessons
so you clarence for dan i remember that
i haven't heard that name in forever
so there you are with the chargers
and then so was that did you were you on
the team that made the super bowl or
were you is that no
let me tell you the heartbreak that is
the nfl is that i was on the team right
before that came back to camp went all
the way down to the wire and got cut
before in 1994
and they kept calling me all year saying
that they were going to bring me back
and never did and they went all the way
to super bowl this was hard bobby ross
was the coach is that the guy bobby ross
exactly my coach dale lindsey was the
linebacker coach and bobby ross was the
coach and they kept saying yeah we're
going to bring you back bobby beathard
that was bobby beathard's team back then
and uh yeah
and i just was man and i stayed in town
and waited and waited and it never
happened
the heartbreak of first of all all the
heartbreak i went through in nfl got me
ready for hollywood for real
yeah
because you get to be
but you have to face rejection i mean
hollywood is rejection i mean if you can
stand the rejection you're gonna make it
because it's all no it's just all kind
of audition audition you never hear
anything and no one will ever tell you
that you're you're not going to make it
like they all say it's going to be great
and then they never call you so it gets
you super ready for rejection you just
learn to just keep going
and i did that i played seven years in
the nfl
on six different teams i mean all over
the place right and it was just because
i didn't quit and i realized you know
what i could keep doing this but in
hollywood why not do you have a good
life do you have a good junior shell
story
terry wow first of all oh man
you know a junior was a warrior at i
mean at his heart man i
the big big junior junior sales story i
have
is i remember we had a specific play
that was drawn up
uh you know
he was supposed to drop back in coverage
and it was like cover two whatever
he just decided he was just gonna rush
he just decided no i'm gonna blitz and
everybody was like oh i remember
watching like what is he doing
and he literally got the quarterback he
got a fact
and every time he he made those moves
like that all the time but it would
always work for him he had a you know he
had a true spidey sense when it came to
the you know the nfl field
it was like spidey sense he decided he
was just going gonna go and it always
worked when i tried that it was like
what the hell are you doing
you know i got chewed out i was like i'm
gonna rest they're like what the hell
right
right i'm sure i think i might have told
you this and if that's the case then i'm
sorry but because you know all that time
we did spend over the summer just
waiting around to to shoot but um i
remember my my first time i ever saw
junior say out terry was the rose bowl
usc versus michigan it was the last game
in beauchembechler's coaching career i
covered it was the last thing i ever did
as a member of the student newspaper at
michigan and i remember at one point
looking down at the flip chart the flip
card with the names and numbers to see
if there were two number 55s on the
field if they were like if there just
happened to be another 55 because you
know there's like a hundred kids on a
college roster sometimes they they wear
the same number nope oh yeah i kept
looking down i'm like how the hell did
he get there because he was there before
the snap how the hell did he get there
it was one of the greatest performances
i've ever seen in my entire life ever
ever i mean he was like that like i said
he knew what was happening before it
happened it was crazy and we we all i
mean full defense we i remember all
sitting there like hey man
what can we say i mean do what you want
to do bro
you know right i know terry crews here
on the rich eisen show rumble available
for streaming tomorrow exclusively on
paramount plus based on the graphic
novel monster on a hill
you and some very famous names and
voices as well uh good for the kids just
in time for christmas yay
yes right great family family movie you
know it reminds me
of my first job in entertainment which
uh i was on a tv show called battle dome
where i played this character named
t-money it was like a wrestling style
american gladiator style show but on
steroids i mean we were putting people
in the hospital it was crazy uh this was
1999 and i was you know they put me in a
cage set the ends on fire and i wrestled
contestants and whoever was left
standing in the cage
won the prize come on it sounds like
running man terry that's like oh it was
it was well listen it was pre-mma like
people had really you know that's back
when in the you know mixed martial arts
we're in bars and the whole thing you
have big butter beans you know they're
battling people and stuff for me
this was crazy because it was i was
fresh out of the nfl but it was my first
job in entertainment so this was where i
got the whole thing about sports and
entertainment which kind of
it's both you know and i played it up
real big it was like grand theater and
the whole thing and this rumble movie
reminded me totally because it's all
about these monsters who battle on
behalf of their cities and we have all
of these other wwe superstars in the
movie and it just reminded me of my
humble beginnings how it's how it all
started that's why i knew i had to be
involved yeah i know roman reigns is in
it speaking of wwe
um yeah stephen a smith do we consider
him a wrestling star and someone said
he's got he's got the the bravado
entertainment part
i would say so
i would say so he could wrestle you know
he just wrestled with the mic you know
you know guys get up there and they do
these like 20-minute speeches before
they even oh yeah you know before any
wrestling happens that's dna i feel
absolutely will arnett tony danza for
those of you guys are old school right
there that's pretty good yeah yeah
i can't wait this will be great for for
my kids and uh and i don't to watch it
they they came home from summer camp and
watched our uh our jonas brothers uh
venture too terry and they're all big
fans of yours you know they love
brooklyn nine-nine so they all they you
know
i got daddy points for hanging with you
so i appreciate that you know
rich i have to tell you man there's just
not enough you know when you look at
entertainment everything's really
segmented right now you know you can
have a three-year-old watching something
you got a seven-year-old watching
something you got a 14 year old i love
being involved with family entertainment
this is why i love agts that's why i
love movies like this where everybody
can like all right now we can all sit
down and then afterwards have a
conversation about what we just saw
that's those are valuable times because
it's just rare well rumbled again is
going to be on paramount plus starting
tomorrow uh terry you take care of
yourself have a great holiday let's do
this in person next time uh you got it
man you got it rich thank you so much
brother happy holidays you and your
family right back at you that's terry
crews everybody right here on the uh the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here